es una de las imágenes del año reino
unido comenzó la vacunación masiva
contra el cob y 19 con la solución de
fisher y bryant tech la primera persona
en recibirla fue marca de keenan de 90
años quien ya piensa en cómo celebrarlo
bien de barbados o algún lugar
una noticia histórica que por fin da
esperanza para imaginar una vuelta a la
normalidad en 2021
el mejor maestro del mundo 2020 ha sido
ranjit cindy sale de india un
reconocimiento de un millón de dólares
que disa le anunció que repartirá en un
50% con el resto de maestros finalistas
es el primero en hacerlo desde la
fundación del premio en 2015 y creo que
todos los finalistas podemos marcar la
diferencia y hacer de este mundo un
lugar mejor el mérito de dis al
transformar la educación de las niñas de
una escuela rural rediseñando los libros
de texto en su idioma local e
incorporando códigos qr para facilitar
el acceso a materiales de aprendizaje
[Música]
ha sucedido en uno de los países más
futboleros del mundo y es histórico la
asociación argentina de fútbol autorizó
quemar a gómez dispute el torneo de
fútbol de primera división femenino en
el equipo villa san carlos su
particularidad ser una mujer trans
y gracias al fuego que aparece al poco
tiempo
lo toma como una terapia
realmente logró la completa
la contención que yo necesitaba en ese
momento
la lucha de gómez viene de lejos un
tiempo en el que ha tenido que convencer
a la dirigencia del fútbol argentino de
que no posee ventaja física y que puede
convertirse en la primera futbolista
transgénero del país
[Música]
la cetrería es la tradición de criar
entrenar y usar halcones para la caza
que hoy en el golfo pérsico es un
deporte se trata de un contexto
exclusivamente masculino en el que ha
irrumpido la saudita qatar ya alcalde la
primera etcétera en competir en el arte
de amaestrar halcones la cetrería es un
legado conocido desde la antigüedad y
nos orgullecemos de ello por lo que yo
pueda participar y probar mis
habilidades demuestra que las mujeres
también podemos competir el festival de
cetrería rey abdulaziz ha sacado pecho
por la presencia de alcalde y ha honrado
su participación en el concurso
[Música]
en kenia cuatro ingenieros han unido
esfuerzos contra los desechos de
plástico con la fundación
makers una iniciativa en la que reciclan
tapas de botella de plástico y
contenedores de aceite de cocina para
convertirlos en ladrillos los desechos
son recolectados antes de llegar a los
vertederos y tras un proceso de
reciclaje llegan a la línea de
producción con una fabricación de 1500
ladrillos diarios
[Música]
islamabad la capital de pakistán tiene
una de las tasas más altas de
deforestación en asia y en 50 años
podría quedarse sin bosques
ante esta situación nació el proyecto
lanzar y cultivar que elabora unas bolas
de arcilla y abono que llevan adentro
semillas estas bolas son arrojadas a los
bosques para que puedan germinar semanas
después ya han lanzado un millón y medio
en un esfuerzo comunitario por
reforestar el país
ah